millions of years ago Earth looked very
different all the continents were fused
into one teaming with life both
beautiful and
terrifying when you think of prehistoric
times you might picture a T-Rex
rampaging through the jungle with its
razor sharp teeth but even before the
dinosaurs there were other giant
creatures ruling the Earth
yeah welcome to the peran period this
epic started 300 million years ago back
then our planet had one supercontinent
Pangia surrounded by a world ocean
called
panthalassa the peran period began at
the end of an ice age when temperatures
were much cooler than today then during
early peran days Earth warmed to a l
environment with a diversity of plants
and a rapid evolution of insect and
animal life only as you probably know
everything is Ever Changing on our Blue
Marble over the next 50 million years
Earth kept growing hotter and drier
eventually the most deadly event in the
history of our planet wiped out nearly
everything that ever lived here
scientists call this event the great
dying and it was the most catastrophic
mass extinction event the Earth has ever
seen and the Earth has seen five of them
but before we get to all this Doom and
Gloom let me take you on an Epic Journey
back in time here in the peran period
some of the most incredible species that
roamed our young Planet are about to
emerge
if you could time travel nearly 300
million years into the past you'd land
smack dab in the middle of the superc
continent Pangia Earth's smaller
continents would have just finished
colliding with each other to form this
enormous land mass taking up onethird of
the planet's
surface there was likely less oxygen in
the air than there is now but you still
might be able to breathe oh and bring a
jacket because it it would likely be
chilly with some areas averaging no more
than a Brisk 4°
C but don't worry things will soon start
heating up by the end of the early
perian the Ice Age was on its way out
and Pangia was becoming a lush
world plants and animals started to
thrive this was a volcanic World violent
eruptions changed the climate climate
shaped the landscape and paved the way
for
evolution when giant swamp forests began
drying out plant life had to adapt and
so 290 million years ago Earth saw the
very first seed-bearing plants called
gymnosperms these plants carried seeds
on their cones and they spread across
the supercontinent like
wildfire the ancient evergreen forest of
the early peran was hiding something
familiar just like today you could find
cicas and beetles piercing and sucking
on the plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches only these weren't the
Cockroaches you know today these
prehistoric Vermin were gigantic the
size of
birds but despite their size cockroaches
never ruled prehistoric land and that's
good news am I right no something much
more fascinating was roaming Pangia the
now extinct ancestor of primitive
mammals
dimetrodon this animal was as
fascinating as it was
terrifying encountering a dimetrodon
would be quite a sight to behold this
ancient lizard grew to 5 m long and
weighed 225
kg it had a large sail running down its
spine scientists think this sail helped
the reptile regulate its body
temperature soaking up warmth during the
daytime and dissipating excess heat
during the cooler nights it would walk
toward you like a crocodile and act like
a total Menace dimetrodon was an apex
predator of its time watch out for a mix
of sharp and flat teeth that would slice
you open and grind you
up in the middle perian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet
therapsids they had strong jaws with
sharp teeth and a somewhat upright
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies thpid
reptiles varied from the 5 m long likely
omnivorous dudosa surus to the five
times smaller median
lops you could meet plenty more
therapsids if you stuck around for
another 20 million
years during the middle peran period
Earth kept getting hotter the average
global temperature on Pia grew to about
25° C and volcanoes were spitting
greenhouse gases out into the atmosphere
due to the changing climate sea levels
were shifting but marine life found ways
to
thrive if you were to take a dip in the
prehistoric super ocean you'd be
swimming alongside ancient Shar shks and
bony primitive fish many more complex
marine species came and went as the
environment kept
changing in the late peran period you
could have a friendly encounter with
another reptile
lystrosaurus these looked like a cross
between a lizard and a pig but unlike
all the scary prehistoric monsters out
there lystrosaurus was a herbivore it
was just 1 M long and had powerful front
legs for burrowing soon another cute
mamal likee lizard evolved the
codon the codon looked like a giant
rodent it was about 1 M long had
whiskers and fed on small animals and
insects now during this time something
bad was brewing in the air a large
amount of volcanic activity was
displacing O oxygen from the atmosphere
scientists think there was as little as
10% oxygen in the air compare that to
21% today you'd have a hard time
breathing in that environment and the
temperature kept rising and Rising with
an average temperature of about 28° C
this Lush prehistoric world was turning
into an
oven all good things must come to an end
and sadly this period came to a
particularly brutal one about 252
million years ago about 90% of all plant
and animal life was wiped out this
tragic moment is called the Great dying
and it was Earth's most devastating mass
extinction event scientists still debate
what caused this catastrophic Extinction
most theories suggest it was the the
result of explosive volcanic activity as
huge volcanic eruptions swept the
continent massive amounts of Ash were
Unleashed into the atmosphere so much
Ash that it blocked out most if not all
of the incoming sunlight and with no
sunlight global temperatures dropped
suddenly plants couldn't perform their
photosynthetic processes and died off
and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon
followed things got worse before they
got better because of all the carbon
dioxide emitted during the volcanic
eruptions global temperatures rose again
and not just to where they were but
higher much higher and this caused the
super ocean to lose most of its oxygen
and unable to breathe a majority of the
perian sea animals perished eventually
over 95% of marine species and More than
70% of land animals became
extinct 66 million years ago an asteroid
as big as Mount Everest was headed on a
deadly Collision Course with
Earth the impact was so devastating that
it wiped out the most gigantic deadliest
reptiles to ever roam our planet
but the dinosaurs didn't just die from
one big boom no they faced a slow
agonizing
end how did this Extinction event cause
the largest tsunami Earth has ever
seen and what exactly happened after the
big reptiles were
gone Hold On Tight we're taking you on
the most epic and deadly trip of your
life
this dinosaur ending asteroid is
terrifying Not only was it about 10 km
in diameter but it also traveled
incredibly fast between 10 and 30 kilm
per
second at this point it was a blazing
Fireball as it hurdled down to earth the
air in front of it was compressing and
heating up to unimaginably hot
temperatures
just before the impact the asteroid
could have been as hot as the surface of
the
Sun once it entered our atmosphere it
only took this massive Space Rock a few
seconds to reach Earth's
surface and alter the course of life
forever as the asteroids slammed into
Earth off the coast of where Mexico is
now it sent huge amounts of debris up
into the the air the shocking blast wave
killed everything in its way and from
here it was only getting
worse this powerful blast ejected bits
of the Earth's surface into the
atmosphere and minutes later scorching
hot pieces of glass and rock rained back
down some of the debris reacted with the
atmosphere causing acid rain that would
last for years the land was burning
the fires caused by this devastating
impact spread across the continent like
literal Wildfire killing more and more
Life along the way and then just when
you thought the apocalyptic scenario
couldn't get any more
intense well it
did the impact of the asteroid hitting
Earth was so powerful that it sent shock
waves through the
planet and all that energy had to go
somewhere cue the meat
tsunami a wall of water over 10 m High
raced across the
ocean this wasn't your regular tsunami
it was a staggering 30,000 times more
powerful than anything you see
today as this monstrous wave spread
across the North Atlantic and South
pafic coastlines didn't stand a chance
the wave hit with such force that it
destroyed and reshaped the continent if
you were there to witness this
apocalyptic destruction well you
wouldn't survive any of it but some
dinosaurs did yeah the ones further away
from Ground Zero weren't immediately
obliterated by the impact they weren't
incinerated by the resulting infernos
and they managed to avoid being Swept
Away by the mega tsunami but still their
fate was
sealed as the the dust began to settle
it was the start of a nuclear winter
even though it wasn't nuclear weapons
that caused it the effect was the same
the massive amount of debris in the air
blocked the sunlight for months maybe
even years Earth suddenly became a cold
dark place and the Dinos weren't ready
for it as temperatures plummeted and
fires released enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases the CL climate changed
dramatically plants weren't able to
perform photosynthesis and most of them
started to die out this disrupted the
food chain and starved many of the
animals that survived the impact and
remember the acid rain it lasted for
several years causing more Devastation
to the
ecosystems the oceans became too acidic
for marine life most ocean species
didn't have the time to adapt to such a
drastic
change these prolonged harsh conditions
together with the initial blast pushed
about
75% of Earth's life to
Extinction the good news is is that this
included the horrifying
T-Rex yeah as much as I feel bad for
this guy I'm happy he's not running
around
today when the last of the dinosaurs
breathed their last breath Earth became
an empty devastated Place cold and
acidic so when did things get back to
normal yeah well here's the thing they
didn't not dinosaur era normal
anyway Earth didn't rebuild after that
it reinvented
itself 1,000 years later the planet was
recovering from the post apocalyptic
winter it was still cold and food was
still scarce but life was ready to make
a comeback in this new Wild World a few
furry Little Critters were sprinting
around among the first plants to
reappear after the impact were ferns
they really hit it off well after the
disaster 100,000 years later Earth began
to get a little more lively creatures
about the size of raccoons were
repopulating the continents and the
oceans were once again teeming with life
fast forward about 10 million years and
Earth had finally restored its
biodiversity only it wasn't the same
Earth as it used to be now it was the
age of
mammals yeah after the dinosaurs checked
out mammals were on fire yeah not
literally of course mammals together
with birds and flowering plants were
rocking the planet yeah Earth never got
back to its old self after the last
dinosaur died it took our planet
millions of years to bounce back in a
new way but don't get me wrong this
world was still pretty terrifying it had
beasts like
paraceratherium roaming the land and
megalodons reigning Terror in the
oceans yeah it's really for the best
that most of these creatures aren't
around these days
you might have heard that all dinosaurs
were wiped out 65 million years ago when
a 15 km wide asteroid crashed into Earth
and caused a mass extinction
event but that is entirely
false one species of dinosaur theropods
managed to survive they had feathers and
hollow bones and most of them could fly
meaning they could rise above the blast
and survive the aftermath and now many
scientists believe that these theropod
dinosaurs managed to evolve into birds
so technically dinosaurs are still alive
and with us
today but that's not the only thing you
were lied to about dinosaurs from
non-existent species to T-Rex's eyesight
there are many myths and misconceptions
about the Mesozoic Era
one of the craziest is that dinosaurs
were all green scary monsters in fact
many of them likely had feathers
theropods would have had feathers for a
variety of reasons from giving them
warmth to helping some aviation-based
dinos to fly and that's not all
dinosaurs were a variety of colors yeah
some fossils have preserved pigments
showing that not all dinosaurs were
brown black or green
they may have had many vibrant colors
some of them may even have had specific
camouflage depending on their
environment and they weren't all scaly
and slimy either different Dino species
would have different textures to their
skin I want to know if any of them were
fluffy now when you think of dinosaurs
you probably think that they were all
massive the T-Rex had a length of 12 M
and the long neck Brachiosaurus was up
to 13 M tall but that wasn't the case
for all
dinosaurs contrary to popular belief not
all dinosaurs were giants in fact many
of them were pretty small some were even
the size of birds that we have
today look at that
one one small dinosaur was the micro
Raptor this little guy was about the
size of a crow he even had wings and
feathers making him look like a
bird dinos are typically portrayed as
slow-moving coldblooded reptiles but
this isn't totally accurate scientists
have recently discovered that dinosaurs
weren't all coldblooded like we thought
but that doesn't mean that they were all
warm-blooded it's a bit more
complicated dinosaurs may have had a
metabolic system known as mesothermic
this means they were somewhere between
cold and warm-blooded being mesothermic
allows animals to generate some internal
heat just not as much as a warm-blooded
animal would dinosaurs with feathers may
have been warm-blooded feathers usually
suggest warm-blooded now of course there
were thousands of species of dinosaurs
so sure many of them may have been
coldblooded but there were also
warm-blooded and mesothermic dinosaurs
the Brontosaurus is one of the most
iconic dinosaurs ever with its long neck
and tail it's probably one of the first
dinosaurs you think of but did you know
that these creatures almost didn't exist
yeah in the 19th century the
Brontosaurus was accidentally classified
as the Apatosaurus a species with
similar traits it wasn't until 2015
after years of research that the
Brontosaurus was reclassified as its own
dinosaur kind of like how Pluto comes
and goes as a planet the dinosaur
community seems to have some sort of
trouble making up their mind on the
valid of the name
brontosaurus movies like Jurassic Park
often show the Tyrannosaurus Rex as one
of the most deadly predators destroying
everything in its path the only catch
they can only see Ray If It
Moves yeah that's also completely false
to make the T-Rex even more terrifying
they had incredible vision and were
easily able to see prey that Stood Still
since the T-Rex's ey eyes were
positioned forward on its head it had
binocular vision it could easily judge
distances and see objects in three
dimensions similar to how humans see
research suggests that the T-Rex might
have had better eyesight than modern-day
Birds because it had such large optic
nerves it's easy to forget but dinosaurs
didn't all live
simultaneously the Mesozoic Era also
known as the age of dinosaurs spanned
over over 180 million years there were
three distinct periods Triassic Jurassic
and Cretaceous and within these three
periods different species were unique to
the specific era within 180 million
years some dinosaurs evolved into new
forms and some species went
extinct some of the most iconic
dinosaurs like the stegosaurus and T-Rex
never actually coexisted
they lived in entirely different time
periods tens of millions of years
apart also the T-Rex is often shown as a
Godzilla
like
millions of years ago Earth looked very
different all the continents were fused
into one te beaming with life both
beautiful and
terrifying when you think of prehistoric
times you might picture a T-Rex
rampaging through the jungle with its
razor sharp teeth but even before the
dinosaurs there were other giant
creatures ruling the Earth yeah welcome
to the peran period this epic started
300 million years ago back then our
planet had one supercontinent Pangia
surrounded by a world ocean called
panthalassa the perian period began at
the end of an ice age when temperatures
were much cooler than today then during
early peran days Earth warmed to a lush
environment with a diversity of plants
and a rapid evolution of insect and
animal life only as you probably know
everything is Ever Changing on our Blue
Marble over the next 50 million years
Earth kept growing hotter and drier
eventually the most deadly event in the
history of our planet wiped out nearly
everything that ever lived here
scientists called this event the great
dying and it was the most catastrophic
mass extinction event the Earth has ever
seen and the Earth has seen five of them
but but before we get to all this Doom
and Gloom let me take you on an Epic
Journey back in time here in the peran
period some of the most incredible
species that roamed our young Planet are
about to
emerge if you could time travel nearly
300 million years into the past you'd
land smack dab in the middle of the
supercontinent Pangia
Earth's smaller continents would have
just finished colliding with each other
to form this enormous land mass taking
up oneir of the planet's
surface there was likely less oxygen in
the air than there is now but you still
might be able to breathe oh and bring a
jacket because it would likely be chilly
with some areas averaging no more than a
Brisk 4°
C but don't worry things will soon start
heating up
by the end of the early perian the Ice
Age was on its way out and Pangia was
becoming a lush
world plants and animals started to
thrive this was a volcanic World violent
eruptions changed the climate shaped the
landscape and paved the way for
evolution when giant swamp forests began
drying out plant life had to adapt and
so so 290 million years ago Earth saw
the very first seed bearing plants
called gymnos sperms these plants
carried seeds on their cones and they
spread across the super continent like
wildfire the ancient evergreen forest of
the early peran was hiding something
familiar just like today you could find
cicas and beetles piercing and sucking
on the plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches
only these weren't the Cockroaches you
know today these prehistoric Vermin were
gigantic the size of
birds but despite their size cockroaches
never ruled prehistoric land and that's
good news am I right no something much
more fascinating was roaming Pangia the
now extinct ancestor of primitive
mammals
dimetrodon this animal was as fast
fascinating as it was
terrifying encountering a dimetrodon
would be quite a sight to behold this
ancient lizard grew to 5 m long and
weighed 225
kg it had a large sail running down its
spine scientists think this sail helped
the reptile regulate its body
temperature soaking up warmth during the
daytime and dissipating excess heat
during the cooler nights it would walk
to W you like a crocodile and act like a
total Menace dimetrodon was an apex
predator of its time watch out for a mix
of sharp and flat teeth that would slice
you open and grind you
up in the middle perian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet
therapsids they had strong jaws with
sharp teeth and a somewhat upright right
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies
therapsid reptiles varied from the 5 m
long likely omnivorous dudosa surus to
the five times smaller meaning
lops you could meet plenty more
therapsids if you stuck around for
another 20 million
years during the middle perian period
Earth kept getting hotter the average
global temperature on Pangia grew to
about 25 de C and volcanoes were
spitting greenhouse gases out into the
atmosphere due to the changing climate
sea levels were shifting but marine life
found ways to thrive if you were to take
a dip in the prehistoric super ocean
you'd be swimming alongside ancient
sharks and bony primitive fish many more
complex marine species came and went as
the environment kept
changing
in the late peran period you could have
a friendly encounter with another
reptile
lystrosaurus these looked like a cross
between a lizard and a pig but unlike
all the scary prehistoric monsters out
there lystrosaurus was a herbivore it
was just 1 M long and had powerful front
legs for burrowing soon another cute
mamal like lizard evolved the
codon the codon looked like a giant
rodent it was about 1 M long had
whiskers and fed on small animals and
insects now during this time something
bad was brewing in the air a large
amount of volcanic activity was
displacing oxygen from the atmosphere
scientists think there was as little as
10% oxygen in the air compare that to
21% today you'd have a hard time
breathing in that environment and the
temperature kept rising and Rising with
an average temperature of about 28° C
this Lush prehistoric world was turning
into an
oven all good things must come to an end
and sadly this period came to a
particularly brutal one about 252
million years ago about 90% of all plant
and animal life was wiped out this
tragic moment is called the Great dying
and it was Earth's most devastating mass
extinction event scientists still debate
what caused this catastrophic Extinction
most theories suggest it was the result
of explosive volcanic activity as huge
volcanic eruptions swept the continent
massive amounts of Ash were Unleashed
into the atmosphere
so much Ash that it blocked out most if
not all of the incoming sunlight and
with no sunlight global temperatures
dropped suddenly plants couldn't perform
their photosynthetic processes and died
off and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon
followed things got worse before they
got better because of all the carbon
dioxide emitted during the volcanic
eruptions global temperatures rose again
and not just to where they were but
higher much higher and this caused the
super ocean to lose most of its oxygen
and unable to breathe a majority of the
perian sea animals perished eventually
over 95% of marine species and More than
70% of land animals became
extinct 66 milli million years ago an
asteroid as big as Mount Everest was
headed on a deadly Collision Course with
Earth the impact was so devastating that
it wiped out the most gigantic deadliest
reptiles to ever roam our planet but the
dinosaurs didn't just die from one big
boom no they faced a slow agonizing end
how did this Extinction event cause the
largest tsunami Earth has ever
seen and what exactly happened after the
big reptiles were
gone Hold On Tight we're taking you on
the most epic and deadly trip of your
life this dinosaur ending asteroid is
terrifying Not only was it about 10
kilometers in diameter but it also
traveled incredibly fast between 10 and
30 km/
second at this point it was a blazing
Fireball as it hurdled down to earth the
air in front of it was compressing and
heating up to unimaginably hot
temperatures just before the impact the
asteroid could have been as hot as the
surface of the
Sun once it entered our atmosphere it
only took this Mass massive Space Rock a
few seconds to reach Earth's
surface and alter the course of life
forever as the asteroids slammed into
Earth off the coast of where Mexico is
now it sent huge amounts of debris up
into the air the shocking blast wave
killed everything in its way and from
here it was only getting
worse this powerful blast ejected bits
of the Earth's surface into the
atmosphere and minutes later scorching
hot pieces of glass and rock rained back
down some of the debris reacted with the
atmosphere causing acid rain that would
last for years the land was burning the
fires caused by this devastating impact
spread across the continent like literal
Wildfire killing more and more Life
along the way and then just when you
thought the apocalyptic scenario
couldn't get any more
intense well it
did the impact of the asteroid hitting
Earth was so powerful that it sent shock
waves through the
planet and all that energy had to go
somewhere cue the meat
tsunami a wall of water over 10 m High
raced across the
ocean this wasn't your regular tsunami
it was a staggering 30,000 times more
powerful than anything you see
today as this monstrous wave spread
across the North Atlantic and South
Pacific coastlines didn't stand a chance
the wave hit with such force that it
destroyed and reshaped the continent if
you were there to witness this
apocalyptic destruction well you
wouldn't survive any of it but some some
dinosaurs did yeah the ones further away
from Ground Zero weren't immediately
obliterated by the impact they weren't
incinerated by the resulting infernos
and they managed to avoid being Swept
Away by the mega tsunami but still their
fate was
sealed as the dust began to settle it
was the start of a nuclear winter even
though it wasn't nuclear weapons that
caused it the effect was the same the
massive amount of debris in the air
blocked the sunlight for months maybe
even years Earth suddenly became a cold
dark place and the Dinos weren't ready
for it as temperatures plummeted and
fires released enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases the climate changed
dramatically plants weren't able to
perform photosynthesis and most of them
started to die out this disrupted the
food chain and starved many of the
animals that survived the impact and
remember the acid rain it lasted for
several years causing more Devastation
to the
ecosystems the oceans became too acidic
for marine life most ocean species
didn't have the time to adapt to such a
drastic
change these prolonged harsh conditions
together with the initial blast pushed
about
75% of Earth's life to
Extinction the good news is is that this
included the horrifying
T-Rex yeah as much as I feel bad for
this guy I'm happy he's not running
around
today when the last of the dinosaurs
breathed their last breath Earth became
an empty devastated Place cold and
acidic so when did things get back to
normal yeah well here's the thing they
didn't not dinosaur era normal
anyway Earth didn't rebuild after that
it reinvented
itself 1,000 years later the planet was
recovering from the post-apocalyptic
winter it was still cold and food was
still scarce but life was ready to make
a comeback in this new Wild World a a
few furry Little Critters were sprinting
around among the first plants to
reappear after the impact were ferns
they really hit it off well after the
disaster 100,000 years later Earth began
to get a little more lively creatures
about the size of raccoons were
repopulating the continents and the
oceans were once again teaming with life
fast forward about 10 million years and
Earth had finally restored its
biodiversity
only it wasn't the same Earth as it used
to be now it was the age of
mammals yeah after the dinosaurs checked
out mammals were on fire yeah not
literally of course mammals together
with birds and flowering plants were
rocking the planet yeah Earth never got
back to its old self after the last
dinosaur died it took our planet
millions of years to bounce back in a
new way but don't get me wrong this
world was still pretty terrifying it had
beasts like par s ethereum roaming the
land and megalodons reigning Terror in
the
oceans yeah it's really for the best
that most of these creatures aren't
around these
days you might have heard that all
dinosaurs were wiped out 65 million
years ago when a 15 km wide asteroid
crashed into Earth and caused a mass
extinction
event but that is entirely
false one species of dinosaur theropods
managed to survive they had feathers and
hollow bones and most of them could fly
meaning they could rise above the blast
and survive the aftermath and now many
scientists believe that these theropod
dinosaurs managed to evolve into Birds
so technically dinosaurs are still alive
and with us
today but that's not the only thing you
were lied to about dinosaurs from
non-existent species to T-Rex's eyesight
there are many myths and misconceptions
about the Mesozoic
Era one of the craziest is that
dinosaurs were all green scary monsters
in fact many of them likely had feathers
th pods would have had feathers for a
variety of reasons from giving them
warmth to helping some aviation-based
dinos to fly and that's not all
dinosaurs were a variety of colors yeah
some fossils have preserved pigments
showing that not all dinosaurs were
brown black or green they may have had
many vibrant colors some of them may
even have had specific camouflage
depending on their
environment and they weren't all scaly
and slimy either different Dino species
would have different textures to their
skin I want to know if any of them were
fluffy now when you think of dinosaurs
you probably think that they were all
massive the T-Rex had a length of 12 M
and the long- necked Brachiosaurus was
up to 13 M tall but that wasn't the case
for all
dinosaurs contrary to popular belief not
all dinosaurs were giants in fact many
of them were pretty small some were even
the size of birds that we have
today look at that
one one small dinosaur was the micro
Raptor this little guy was about the
size of a crow he even had wings and
Feathers making him look like a
bird dinos are typically portrayed as
slow moving coldblooded reptiles but
this isn't totally accurate scientist
have recently discovered that dinosaurs
weren't all coldblooded like we thought
but that doesn't mean that they were all
warm-blooded it's a bit more
complicated dinosaurs may have had a
metabolic system known as mesothermic
this means they were somewhere between
cold and warm-blooded being mesothermic
allows animals to generate some internal
heat just not as much as a warm-blooded
animal W dinosaurs with feathers may
have been warm-blooded feathers usually
suggest warm-blooded now of course there
were thousands of species of dinosaurs
so sure many of them may have been cold
blooded but there were also warm blooded
and mesothermic dinosaurs the
Brontosaurus is one of the most iconic
dinosaurs ever with its long neck and
tail it's probably one of the first
dinosaurs you think of but did you know
that these creatures almost didn't exist
yeah in the 19th century the
Brontosaurus was accidentally classified
as the Apatosaurus a species with
similar traits it wasn't until 2015
after years of research that the
Brontosaurus was reclassified as its own
dinosaur kind of like how Pluto comes
and goes as a planet the dinosaur
community seems to have some sort of
trouble making up their mind on the
validity of the name
brontosaurus movies like Jurassic Park
often show the Tyrannosaurus Rex as one
of the most deadly predators destroying
every everything in its path the only
catch they can only see prey If It
Moves yeah that's also completely false
to make the T-Rex even more terrifying
they had incredible vision and were
easily able to see prey that Stood Still
since the T-Rex's eyes were positioned
forward on its head it had binocular
vision it could easily judge distances
and see objects in three dimensions
similar to how humans see research
suggests that the T-Rex might have had
better eyesight than modern-day Birds
because it had such large optic
nerves it's easy to forget but dinosaurs
didn't all live
simultaneously the Mesozoic Era also
known as the age of dinosaurs spanned
over 180 million years there were three
distinct periods Triassic Jurassic and
Cretaceous and with within these three
periods different species were unique to
the specific era within 180 million
years some dinosaurs evolved into new
forms and some species went
extinct some of the most iconic
dinosaurs like the stegosaurus and T-Rex
never actually coexisted they lived in
entirely different time periods tens of
millions of years
apart also the T-Rex is often shown as a
Godzilla likee
I
millions of years ago Earth looked very
different all the continents were fused
into one teaming with life both
beautiful and
terrifying when you think of prehistoric
times you might picture a T-Rex
rampaging Through the Jungle with its
razor sharp teeth but even before the
dinosaurs there were other giant
creatures ruling the Earth yeah welcome
to the peran period this epic started
300 million years ago back then our
planet had one supercontinent Pangia
surrounded by a world ocean called
panthalassa the peran period began at
the end of of an ice age when
temperatures were much cooler than today
then during early peran days Earth
warmed to a lush environment with a
diversity of plants and a rapid
evolution of insect and animal life only
as you probably know everything is Ever
Changing on our Blue Marble over the
next 50 million years Earth kept growing
hotter and drier eventually the most
deadly event in the history of our
planet wiped out nearly everything that
ever lived here scientists called this
event the great dying and it was the
most catastrophic mass extinction event
the Earth has ever seen and the Earth
has seen five of them but before we get
to all this Doom and Gloom let me take
you on an Epic Journey back in time here
in the peran period some of the most
incred incredible species that roamed
our young Planet are about to
emerge if you could time travel nearly
300 million years into the past you'd
land smack dab in the middle of the
superc continent Pangia Earth's smaller
continents would have just finished
colliding with each other to form this
enormous land mass taking up onethird of
the planet's surface there was likely
less oxygen in the air than there is now
but you still might be able to breathe
oh and bring a jacket because it would
likely be chilly with some areas
averaging no more than a Brisk 4°
C but don't worry things will soon start
heating up by the end of the early peran
the Ice Age was on its way out and
Pangia was becoming a lush
world plants and animals started to
thrive
this was a volcanic World violent
eruptions changed the climate shaped the
landscape and paved the way for
evolution when giant swamp forests began
drying out plant life had to adapt and
so 290 million years ago Earth saw the
very first seed bearing plants called
gymnosperms these plants carried seeds
on their cones and they spread across
the supercontinent like
wildfire the ancient evergreen forest of
the early peran was hiding something
familiar just like today you could find
cicas and beetles piercing and sucking
on the plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches only these weren't the
Cockroaches you know today these
prehistoric Vermin were gigantic the
size of
birds but despite their size cockroaches
never ruled prehistoric land and that's
good news am I right no something much
more fascinating was roaming Pangia the
now extinct ancestor of primitive
mammals
dimetrodon this animal was as
fascinating as it was
terrifying encountering a dimetrodon
would be quite a sight to behold this
ancient lizard grew to 5 m long and
weighed 225
kg it had a large sail running down its
spine scientists think this saale helped
the reptile regulate its body
temperature soaking up warmth during the
daytime and dissipating excess heat
during the cooler nights it would walk
toward you like a crocodile and act like
a total
Menace dimetrodon was an apex predator
of its time watch out for a mix of sharp
and flat teeth that would slice you open
and grind you
up in the middle perian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet
therapsids they had strong jaws with
sharp teeth and a somewhat upright
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies
therapsid reptiles varied from the 5 m
long likely omnivorous dorus aurus to
the five times smaller meaning
lops you could meet plenty more
therapsids if you stuck around for
another 20 million
years during the middle perian period
Earth kept getting hotter the average
global temperature on Pangia grew to
about 25° C and volcanoes were spitting
greenhouse gases out into the atmosphere
due to the changing climate sea levels
were shifting but marine life found ways
to thrive if you were to take a dip in
the prehistoric super ocean you'd be
swimming alongside ancient sharks and
bony primitive fish many more complex
marine species came and went as the
environment kept
changing in the late peran period you
could have a friendly encounter with
another reptile
lystrosaurus these looked like a cross
between a lizard and a pig but unlike
all the scary prehistoric monsters out
there lystrosaurus was a
herbivore it was just 1 M long and had
powerful front legs for burrowing soon
another cute mammal-like lizard evolved
the
codon the codon looked like a giant
rodent it was about 1 M long had
whiskers and fed on small animals and
insects
now during this time something bad was
brewing in the air a large amount of
volcanic activity was displacing oxygen
from the atmosphere scientists think
there was as little as 10% oxygen in the
air compare that to 21% today you'd have
a hard time breathing in that
environment and the temperature kept
rising and Rising with an average
temperature of about 28° C
this Lush prehistoric world was turning
into an
oven all good things must come to an end
and sadly this period came to a
particularly brutal one about 252
million years ago about 90% of all plant
and animal life was wiped out this
tragic moment is called the Great dying
and it was Earth's most devastating mass
extinction event scientists still debate
what caused this catastrophic Extinction
most theories suggest it was the result
of explosive volcanic activity as huge
volcanic eruptions swept the continent
massive amounts of Ash were Unleashed
into the atmosphere so much Ash that it
blocked out most if not all of the
incoming sunlight and with no sunlight
global temperatures dropped suddenly
plants couldn't perform their
photosynthetic processes and died off
and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon
followed things got worse before they
got better because of all the carbon
dioxide emitted during the volcanic
eruptions global temperatures rose again
and not just to where they were but
higher much higher and this caused the
super ocean to lose most of its oxygen
and unable to breathe a majority of the
perian sea animals
perished eventually over 95% of marine
species and More than 70% of land
animals became
extinct 66 million years ago an asteroid
as big as Mount Everest was headed on a
deadly Collision Course with
Earth
the impact was so devastating that it
wiped out the most gigantic deadliest
reptiles to ever roam our planet but the
dinosaurs didn't just die from one big
boom no they faced a slow agonizing
end how did this Extinction event cause
the largest tsunami Earth has ever
seen and what exactly happened after the
big reptiles were
gone Hold On Tight we're taking you on
the most epic and deadly trip of your
life this dinosaur ending asteroid is
terrifying Not only was it about 10 km
in diameter but it also traveled
incredibly fast between 10 and 30 km/
second at this point it was a blazing
fire a ball as it hurdled down to earth
the air in front of it was compressing
and heating up to unimaginably hot
temperatures just before the impact the
asteroid could have been as hot as the
surface of the
Sun once it entered our atmosphere it
only took this massive Space Rock a few
seconds to reach Earth's surface and
alter the course of life
forever
as the asteroid slammed into Earth off
the coast of where Mexico is now it sent
huge amounts of debris up into the air
the shocking blast wave killed
everything in its way and from here it
was only getting
worse this powerful blast ejected bits
of the Earth's surface into the
atmosphere and minutes later scorching
hot pieces of glass and rock rained back
down some of the debris reacted with the
atmosphere causing acid rain that would
last for years the land was burning the
fires caused by this devastating impact
spread across the continent like literal
Wildfire killing more and more Life
along the way and then just when you
thought the apocalyptic scenario
couldn't get any more
intense well it
did the Imp of the asteroid hitting
Earth was so powerful that it sent shock
waves through the
planet and all that energy had to go
somewhere cue the meat
tsunami a wall of water over 10 m High
raced across the
ocean this wasn't your regular tsunami
it was a staggering 30,000 times more
powerful than anything you see
today as this monstrous w wav spread
across the North Atlantic and South
Pacific coastlines didn't stand a chance
the wave hit with such force that it
destroyed and reshaped the continent if
you were there to witness this
apocalyptic destruction well you
wouldn't survive any of it but some
dinosaurs did yeah the ones further away
from Ground Zero weren't immediately
obliterated by the impact they weren't
incinerated by the resulting infernos
and they managed to avoid being Swept
Away by the mega tsunami but still their
fate was
sealed as the dust began to settle it
was the start of a nuclear winter even
though it wasn't nuclear weapons that
caused it the effect was the same the
massive amount of debris in the air
blocked the sunlight for months maybe
even years Earth suddenly became a cold
dark place and the dino those weren't
ready for it as temperatures plummeted
and fires released enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases the climate changed
dramatically plants weren't able to
perform photosynthesis and most of them
started to die out this disrupted the
food chain and starved many of the
animals that survived the impact and
remember the acid rain it lasted for
several years causing more Devastation
to the ecos systems the oceans became
too acidic for marine life most ocean
species didn't have the time to adapt to
such a drastic
change these prolonged harsh conditions
together with the initial blast pushed
about
75% of Earth's life to
Extinction the good news is is that this
included the horrifying
T-Rex yeah as much as I feel bad for
this guy I'm happy he's not running
around
today when the last of the dinosaurs
breathed their last breath Earth became
an empty devastated Place cold and
acidic so when did things get back to
normal yeah well here's the thing they
didn't not dinosaur AA normal
anyway Earth didn't rebuild after that
it reinvented
itself 1,000 years later the planet was
recovering from the post-apocalyptic
winter it was still cold and food was
still scarce but life was ready to make
a comeback in this new Wild World a few
furry Little Critters were sprinting
around among the first plants to
reappear after the impact were ferns
they really hit it off well after the
disaster
100,000 years later Earth began to get a
little more lively creatures about the
size of raccoons were repopulating the
continents and the oceans were once
again teeming with life fast forward
about 10 million years and Earth had
finally restored its
biodiversity only it wasn't the same
Earth as it used to be now it was the
age of
mammals yeah after the dinosaurs checked
out mammals were on fire yeah not
literally of course mammals together
with birds and flowering plants were
rocking the planet yeah Earth never got
back to its old self after the last
dinosaur died it took our planet
millions of years to bounce back in a
new way but don't get me wrong this
world was still pretty terrifying it had
beasts like
parum Ro the land and megalodons
reigning Terror in the
oceans yeah it's really for the best
that most of these creatures aren't
around these
days you might have heard that all
dinosaurs were wiped out 65 million
years ago when a 15 km wide asteroid
crashed into Earth and caused a mass
extinction
event but that is entirely
false one species of dinosaur theropods
managed to survive they had feathers and
hollow bones and most of them could fly
meaning they could rise above the blast
and survive the aftermath and now many
scientists believe that these theropod
dinosaurs managed to evolve into birds
so technically dinosaurs are still alive
and with us
today but that's not the only thing you
were lied to about dinosaurs from non
existent species to T-Rex's eyesight
there are many myths and misconceptions
about the Mesozoic
Era one of the craziest is that
dinosaurs were all green scary monsters
in fact many of them likely had feathers
theropods would have had feathers for a
variety of reasons from giving them
warmth to helping some aviation-based
dinos to fly and that's not all
dinosaurs were a variety of colors yeah
some fossils have preserved pigments
showing that not all dinosaurs were
brown black or green they may have had
many vibrant colors some of them may
even have had specific camouflage
depending on their
environment and they weren't all scaly
and slimy either different Dino species
would have different textures to their
skin I want to know if any of them were
fluffy now when you think of dinosaurs
you probably think that they were all
massive the T-Rex had a length of 12 M
and the long- necked Brachiosaurus was
up to 13 M tall but that wasn't the case
for all
dinosaurs contrary to popular belief not
all dinosaurs were giants in fact many
of them were pretty small some were even
the size of birds that we have
today look at that one
one small dinosaur was the micro Raptor
this little guy was about the size of a
crow he even had wings and Feathers
making him look like a
bird dinos are typically portrayed as
slow moving coldblooded reptiles but
this isn't totally accurate scientists
have recently discovered that dinosaurs
weren't all coldblooded like we thought
but that doesn't mean that they were all
warm-blooded it's a bit more
complicated dinosaurs may have had a
metabolic system known as mesothermic
this means they were somewhere between
cold and warm-blooded being mesothermic
allows animals to generate some internal
heat just not as much as a warm-blooded
animal would dinosaurs with feathers may
have been warm-blooded feathers usually
suggest warm-blooded now of course there
were thousands of species of dinosaurs
so sure many of them may have been cold
blooded but there were also warm-blooded
and mesothermic dinosaurs
the Brontosaurus is one of the most
iconic dinosaurs ever with its long neck
and tail it's probably one of the first
dinosaurs you think of but did you know
that these creatures almost didn't exist
yeah in the 19th century the
Brontosaurus was accidentally classified
as the Apatosaurus a species with
similar traits it wasn't until 2015
after years of research that the
Brontosaurus was reclassified as its own
dinosaur kind of like how Pluto comes
and goes as a planet the dinosaur
community seems to have some sort of
trouble making up their mind on the
validity of the name
brontosaurus movies like Jurassic Park
often show the Tyrannosaurus Rex as one
of the most deadly predators destroying
everything in its path the only catch
they can only see Ray If It
Moves yeah that's also completely false
to make the T-Rex even more terrifying
they had incredible vision and were
easily able to see prey that Stood Still
since the T-Rex's eyes were positioned
forward on its head it had binocular
vision it could easily judge distances
and see objects in three dimensions
similar to how humans see research
suggests that the T-Rex might have had
better eyesight than modern-day Birds
because it had such large optic
nerves it's easy to forget But Dinosaurs
didn't all live
simultaneously the Mesozoic Era also
known as the age of dinosaurs spanned
over 180 million years there were three
distinct periods Triassic Jurassic and
Cretaceous and within these three
periods different species were unique to
the specific era within 180 million
years some dinosaurs evolved into new
forms and some speci went
extinct some of the most iconic
dinosaurs like the stegosaurus and T-Rex
never actually coexisted they lived in
entirely different time periods tens of
millions of years
apart also the T-Rex is often shown as a
Godzilla
likee
I